so a few months ago I had created a
series on verses characters where I
basically took two caliber characters
from Marvel and DC and I pit them
against one another to see who would win
and it really seemed to be popular with
you guys a lot of you guys really really
seem to like it but at the time my
channel was kind of going through waxes
and wanes so I had to sort of vacate it
for a time but I want to bring it back
but I figure if I'm going to do that
what better way to kick that off
at least a test the waters and see if
they're still interest in it then to do
the DC versus Marvel crossover now for
those of you guys who don't know Marvel
and DC had had crossovers for quite some
time and it really just started out with
an experiment with Superman and
spider-man but it proved to be wildly
successful and Marvel and DC did this
with their most popular characters there
was a Punisher Batman crossover so on
and so forth with the 1990s the Kalibak
industry was on the verge of collapse
just because you had the speculator boom
you had the great you know comic bubble
of the 1990s and I've got a great big
series on that in my valiant my valiant
comics videos you guys are welcome to
check out you'll find that video down in
the description but the result was that
Marvel and DC decided to pull out all
the stops in 1995 and 1996 and basically
bring these crossovers to a head and
have a company-wide crossover and so
what this does is it splits it basically
takes the the 11 best heroes from Marvel
and from DC and it puts them against one
another to see who will win but the way
this was done is half of the fights
we're basically determined to I guess
six of the fights were determined by the
publishers and the other fights were
determined by fans and so what we do as
we get into this is we initially pick up
with spider-man now something to point
out here is this spider-man is not Peter
Parker this spider-man is actually Ben
Riley now for those of you guys who
don't know Ben Riley was the second
clone of spider-man created by The
Jackal miles Warren and the idea was to
basically subvert spider-man's legacy uh
the original owner I guess the first one
was Kane but this Hall sort of led into
the clone slaughter where the question
was its Peter Parker clone has been
Riley or as Kane the actual spider-man
yeah the actual Peter Parker I how does
this whole thing tie into itself and
actually clone saga in a lot of ways
drove people away from comics but the
result was that
you know Ben Riley it kind of become a
mainstay and Marvel Comics at the time
and so because of this while Peter
Parker had basically vacated his
position as spider-man in order to
basically raise his child alongside Mary
Jane Watson Ben Riley had taken up the
role of spider-man in his stead and
there's some distinctions here in terms
of the costumes you know so that we as
readers can tell the differences between
the two but what the story does is it
shows Ben Riley going about you know New
York and just doing his normal thing you
know where he's just patrolling the
streets so on and so forth but he
eventually comes across an alleyway
where he's pulled into a dimensional
rift and the result is that he's yanked
into Gotham City and he encounters the
Joker in this is a funny thing about
this because the Joker has met
spider-man before there was a Spiderman
Batman crossover when they went against
the Joker and carnage I believe and the
result was that of course spider-man in
Batman 1 but for the Joker he remembers
spider-man the issue here is that
because this is not Peter Parker
Ben Wylie doesn't know who the Joker is
and so Ben Riley's really trying to try
to gain his bearings around here and
because he doesn't know how dangerous
the Joker is he doesn't really provoke
him he's just kind of like you know what
are what's going on here who are you
that kind of thing he's really more
curious about a situation than he has
anything else and the jumpers that kind
of laugh things off here so the Joker
basically just bails out and gives Ben
Riley his signature card now from here
we transition to the x-men and the x-men
are basically battling you know the
juggernaut which this isn't designed to
be anything significant this is
something just designed to show us what
the x-men were doing at the ton because
the juggernaut was really one of the
most formidable foes being the brother
of Charles Xavier it makes sense that
Marvel and DC would show us battling or
show the X been battling juggernaut but
in the midst of their conflict Cain
Marko basically vanishes he disappears
and when he really in the tropi 'less
and he comes face to face with Superman
now what it is that happens between the
two of them is not something that we
immediately see instead we actually pick
up with a new creation a character who's
named access and now access is an
interesting scenario here because he was
created in this story he had never
existed in either Marvel or DC and we're
actually going to learn there's a little
more about him
initially given to us but he was
basically the homeless guy who was
sitting alongside this cardboard box
when bin Riley was pulled into it and
ended up in Gotham City and the
indication here from access is for some
reason these universes are starting to
you know people are crossing over
between these two realities and it seems
as though this has happened before and
it's continuing to happen even though it
shouldn't now again this is left
very mysterious here this is left you
know very confusing to us and so what we
do is we switch over to Captain America
in New York and Captain America is
basically just fighting bad guys because
again this these sections of the story
whereby we're seeing what the characters
are doing when they're being yanked in
are just designed to show us what the
characters are doing with Captain
America he's just fighting bad guys he's
just doing his own thing but again he
vanishes and so what DC and Marvel do is
instead of giving us these long drawn
explanations on what characters are
getting into at the time instead they
play it very fast and they play it very
loose in the sense that Wonder Woman is
in the midst of saving you know people's
lives while there's a bridge collapsing
and then suddenly she vanishes we pick
up with the Incredible Hulk The
Incredible Hulk Rouge banner is spending
time with Betty Ross and he vanishes now
the Incredible Hulk is actually an
interesting situation here and the
reason why I say that is because this is
not Savage Hulk this is actually it's
basically Professor Hulk this is an
instance way by The Incredible Hulk has
the mind of Bruce Banner but does not
have his full unbridled strike now this
is something that I want you to keep in
mind because when it comes to the
Incredible Hulk
Superman conflict we're actually going
to see things turn out an interesting
way and it's gonna be one of the reasons
why there's so much debate on the
Incredible Hulk vs. Superman idea but
from here we switch to Conner Kent now
with Superboy this is again you know
after the death and return of Superman
and so for those of you guys who don't
know about that story it was basically
DC trying to find a way to make Superman
relevant and the most logical way to do
it seemed to be to kill him off and then
bring him back but while he was gone DC
lost a story called reign of the
Superman where we got the Eradicator we
got cyborg we got John Henry iron steel
and we got Superboy this is basically
the continuation of his story just
because he was so wildly popular when he
first showed up he was your
quintessential 1990s superhero he had
the leather jacket he had the sunglasses
the whole nine yards and fans absolutely
loved him and so because of that he
stuck around and so again just like
everybody else he gets
yanked into another universe he gets
yanked into a different reality and so
we end up switching over to Lobo in deep
space and again Lobos just doing his
thing where he's just ripping stuff up
and he gets yanked as well and this is
this is basically the pattern that
happens with every single person while
the x-men are trying to figure out what
happened with Kane Marko while they're
trying to figure out where it was that
he was teleported to we end up seeing
that Wolverine that gambit and storm are
teleported away Kyle Rayner Elektra Thor
the flash Wally West Aquaman
silver surfer Shazam name of the
Submariner Quicksilver Catwoman you know
all these characters are just teleported
away and so what this does is it allows
us to basically jump forward this is
Marvel and DC effectively telling us
there are a lot of characters that have
been pulled in and so for us as the
reader we're going to find that there
are actually some characters that we
haven't seen get pulled in that have
been you know have been forced to switch
realities and the first of these comes
in the form of bullseye now bullseye is
well known to be a daredevil villain he
really achieved the height of his
popularity during Frank Miller's run
when he killed Elektra
but he has been teleported to the
Batcave and of course because he's a
villain the first thing he does is he
immediately takes Robin hostage now
because Robin has received such
prodigious training at the hands of
Batman Robin's easily able to counter
bullseye the problem here is that
because bull's-eyes accuracy is so
precise when Batman throws his Batarang
bullseye is able to dodge it the great
thing here though is that this is
basically an illusion this is more or
less a trick and Batman immediately goes
in for the attack and incapacitates
bullseye now the funny thing about this
is bullseye makes a couple comments you
know one of them saying that Batman hits
harder than daredevil and this is really
the height this is really the purpose of
the DC versus Marvel crossover this is
purely a fan driven story and it's
played fast and loose and what I mean by
that is whenever you see crossover
events taking place between publishers
or you see crossover events taking place
within a single publisher Marvel DC
valiant image so on and so forth they
usually give us exposition they give us
a lot of time to absorb everything
that's going on and they usually play it
in a situation to where everything is
given context explanations are usually
given to everything in order to in order
for it to make sense the issue here is
that in the DC vs. Marvel crossover this
doesn't happen
and so with you know Batman and in Tim
Drake so doing bullseye Tim Drake's
immediately teleported away and we don't
really know why but what we do know is
that he's teleported away into the bed
of Jubilee in the Marvel Universe and so
this is effectively how things work now
the second iteration of this comes in
the form of The Daily Planet and Jay
jonah Jameson now as we know Jay jonah
Jameson is he's the Daily Bugle guy and
Marvel Comics but when he appears in The
Daily Planet he basically just takes
over the position of editor-in-chief
we're not told how he does this and
we're not told why he simply just is
he's simply just the guy who's running
the show now and again this is just an
example of them playing everything fast
and loose this is just an example of
them playing everything you know without
a whole lot of exposition here and so at
this point it's basically just a
scenario of Marvel characters versus DC
characters and the question is what's
going on here we initially pick up with
with the absorbing man going against
John Henry iron steel now this is
actually a pretty formidable fight
because you know crusher creel can
basically turn his body into a material
so long as he touches it and so going
against John Henry irons going against
steel if he touches you know John Henry
and Jenna for him he'll make his body
into that material and so from here we
jump to kyle rayner collar is going
against the Green Goblin Captain America
is battling Bane and of course daredevil
is going against the Riddler we also
have Batman who's dealing with venom we
have Shazam who's dealing with Doctor
Doom The Punisher dealing with
Deathstroke as well as Martian Manhunter
and firestorm going against Johnny Storm
and Ben Grimm and this is the pattern
that just keeps repeating itself and
this is why this story was so huge
because it's a dream scenario but what
happens when our favorite character is
the most popular characters from Marvel
and DC basically end up fighting one
another now again a lot of answers
aren't being given here of course you
know Superman playing the role of car
Clark Kent is asking the question to you
know both himself and anybody who
happens to see the situation what's
going on does anybody have any idea
what's happening and so what we do as we
pick up with the end of this first issue
is we basically follow the spectre and
what we find out what the spectre is
that you know he alongside the Living
Tribunal in Marvel Comics are also
trying to understand everything that's
going on but from their perspectives
because a Living Tribunal is
second-in-command to the one above all
to basically god
the marvel universe and because the
spectre is an agent of God the
judeo-christian God in DC Comics the
fact that they don't know what's going
on is a huge deal all they really know
is that things are changing but from
both of their perceptions they also come
to the realization that there are these
two godly beings that have never been
seen before and both of these beings
represent or I guess one that presents
Marvel the other whether represents DC
and they seem to be bridging the gap
between one another in a sense that
they're responsible for the reason for
why these heroes are crossing over with
one another but when that being said
we're gonna bring this video to an end
and if you guys enjoyed this series so
far then then let me know let me know
what you guys think about this first
issue I'm kind of curious because I'll
be honest man I love the the DC vs.
Marvel crossover and the first comic the
first couple comics really are just like
non-stop action that's really all this
series is to be quite frank it's nonstop
action not a lot of exposition and it's
just a series of dream matches but we
will get to a point where by well
actually see uh winners we'll see some
characters from Marvel beating DC and
some characters from DC beating Marvel
and so when we get to that point we'll
cross that bridge when we get to it
for right now if you guys are new to
this channel you know hit the sub button
become part of the robb core drop a like
if you enjoyed it and make sure you
leave a comment let me know what you
guys think so far and yeah I will catch
you guys later peace
[Music]